hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain
an american drama film starring lily
collins call to the bone the movie
begins with ellen a 20 years old college
student who drops out of school because
she is dealing with anorexia she lives
with her stepmother susan and her
stepsister kelly she always does sit-ups
every day to lose weight
when having dinner with her younger
sister she even memorizes and always
counts the number of calories in her
food susan tells her that all this time
her father has been struggling to deal
with her sickness through an inpatient
program but still not making any
progress
she also informs that ellen can return
to her biological mother's home if her
weight has improved
then susan wants to weigh her and finds
out that her condition is getting worse
by the time
with her condition like that her
stepmother decides to take her to a
specialist dr william beckham turns out
ellen's biological mother has some
problems that her biological mother has
bipolar disorder then dr beck checks her
back and finds that her back is bruised
due to excessive sit-ups and her body
starts to get harry trying to keep her
body warm
ellen still thinks that it's fine for
her until dr beck tells her that her
current condition may kill her at any
time he insists that ellen must join his
patient program if she wants to live
she initially is reluctant to do so but
her mind is changed when her half-sister
asks her to do the program for her life
finally she decides to join the patient
program moving into the house with six
other patients with anorexia and bulimia
she is greeted by one of the patients
there named anna there is also luke an
upbeat ballet dancer who is near
recovery from both his anorexia and a
knee injury ellen shares a room with
anna and pearl another patient with
anorexia then luke takes her around the
house starting from the living room
where they do therapy
he also informs her that there is a
point system given by lobo the inpatient
nurse at the house
points are earned for good behavior such
as doing chores
these points can be used for personal
pleasure like going out of the house on
their own well
luke acts as a moral cheerleader for the
other patients and takes a special
interest in ellen eventually revealing
that he is a fan of ellen's art lobo
explains about the rules during meal
time if they eat well and their weight
is close to their target then they can
earn extra points they are also not
allowed to leave the dining table and
all bathrooms are locked for 30 minutes
after meal time to prevent purging
at night dr beck plans to have a family
therapy session for ellen she even does
sit-ups in the middle of the night
the next day at the family therapy
session with dr beck all of her family
comes at the session besides her father
since 18 months earlier ellen was living
with her mother who abandoned her to
move to phoenix arizona with her
mother's partner it is also revealed
that previous artwork she had posted on
tumblr was cited as an influence by a
girl who later killed herself
after the session she promises to try to
do better but instead continues to lose
her weight ellen is trying to make
progress day by day
at one time dr beck tells her that he
doesn't like her name because it's
outdated she agrees with dr beck's
statement and then decides to change her
name to eli
after that she starts bonding with the
other members of the house
she then talks with luke who asks her
out for a dinner date at a restaurant
using the points he has earned
in the end with all the reasons from
luke she decides to go to the restaurant
there she just tastes the food then
vomits it back up
soon she starts to be able to eat a
little bit of cookie however that night
she is surprised when luke kisses her
and admits he is starting to fall in
love with her she panics and quickly
rejects him
later on she learns that megan another
patient in the house is pregnant
unfortunately she miscarries her baby
having resumes her purging after
reaching the 12-week mark and believing
it was safe
the event sends ellen into a tailspin
she starts to not eat again until dr
beck told her that she only has a few
days from getting the feeding tube
then she ignores dr beck and decides to
run away from the house
on her way out luke sadly begs her to
stay telling her that he needs her as he
realizes that his knee condition is
permanent and he will never be able to
properly dance again and need something
new on which to focus but ellen still
leaves him anyway
at the station she feels dizzy and
almost dies due to her condition
worsened luckily she manages to go back
to her biological mother's home
that night her mother expresses her
guilt and says sorry for the postpartum
depression she had after giving birth to
ellen then she suggests that she might
try feeding ellen with a bottle while
rocking her to help solve both their
issues
at first she finds the idea is so
strange but after her mother tells her
that she accepts if ellen chooses death
she decides to go along with the idea
and allows herself to be rocked while
her mother feeds her rice milk from a
bottle
after eating eli goes out for a walk at
midnight not long after she passes out
then she hallucinates that she is in a
tree where she kisses luke who is able
to make her to see how sick she is now
later he gives her a piece of coal that
represents her courage and she decides
to swallow it the next morning she wakes
up from her dream
she immediately returns home and braces
her stepmother and her sister and she
goes to beckham's patient program as she
now has a stronger courage to live
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching